making a statement in the glare of the
public eye dare wears his political
allegiances on his sleeve or rather on
his back a digital display on his
rucksack flashes slogans and symbols
from move forward Thailand's Progressive
political party
I can only hope for one thing democracy
the country has suffered long enough
that sentiment bubbled over in 2020 when
young people took to the streets calling
for the government to step down they
broke the great taboo of Thai politics
demanding the monarchy reform
government Crackdown that followed has
prompted several protesters to try The
Ballot Box rather than the barricades
Toto was one of those protesters now
he's going door to door chasing votes
for move forward
I think we will have to reform the whole
system the elites and the military are
the issue we must fix the problem at
their Roots otherwise we will face the
same issue again in the future
and that's a message that appears to be
reaching well beyond the youth vote part
of their message is to change the
established way of doing things in
Thailand and that message resonates with
more industry younger Generations you're
so appeals to older people who are fed
up with our politics Thai politics has
always been in this deadlock or power
grab between military generals and the
cinema family with the general election
looming the party appears to have kept
the momentum up move forward as
certainly finishing their election
campaign with a flourish pulling out
large crowds and the latest polls
suggest a candidate for prime minister
in Thai politics personalities can be
more important than policies and move
forward's youthful leader has a boy
bandlike appeal but he says it's the
desire for reform that really drives
their support
people are wishing for change in every
aspect of life whether it's the military
demiliteralization the monopolization
decentralization and also find the right
Optimum solution for constitutional
monarchy but votes don't always count in
Thailand the previous incarnation of the
party Future Ford was dissolved by the
courts after coming a close third in the
last election
this time they may be harder to ignore
Tony Chang Al Jazeera Bangkok